[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
police opened a new investigation into
laurie vallo day bell
did she kill one of her ex-husbands new
recordings raise questions
also attorneys seek to move scott
peterson out of san
quentin prison and into a county jail as
a judge decides
whether he deserves an entire new trial
plus the couple who aimed guns at
protesters outside their saint louis
mansion
file a lawsuit against the photographer
and
voters choose police reforms on election
ballots in several major cities
law on crime daily covers court cases
from coast to coast
and welcome to law and crime daily
everybody i'm aaron keller brian
buckmeyer is here with me terry austin
is off today
a newly released audio recording of the
so-called doomsday cult mom lori
valodebel
is leading investigators to look into
murder allegations
velo is charged with conspiracy to
conceal destroy or alter evidence after
the bodies of her two children
turned up buried in a property belonging
to her fifth husband chad dabel
authorities are investigating if more
deaths could be tied to the couple
an audio recording of lori valo from an
informal meeting about religion in
october 2018
was provided to east idaho news which in
turn shared it with law and crime
in the recording velo talks about her
third marriage to joseph ryan
the father of her dead daughter tiley
lori valo is heard making accusations
against ryan during a custody battle
and then cites passages from scriptures
used by the church of latter-day saints
went through a lot of years of of this
kind of hard stuff and
i was going to murder him i was going to
kill him like the scriptures say like
nephi killed it just to stop the pain
and to stop him coming after me and to
stop him coming after my children
and i was just
i just thought i couldn't take it
anymore and i would go through the
scriptures and find all the things like
if he comes against you once if he comes
against you twice if it comes against
you three times then you can kill him it
says it in the scriptures
there it is there's my answer i don't
want to do anything that's wrong
i did not have a murderous heart
i just wanted to stop the bleeding
law and crime executive trial producer
kathy russon has been following this
case since the beginning and explains
the custody battle
from 2004 to joseph ryan's death in 2018
it was a contentious custody dispute
that many years
i have read all 1800 pages of their
court documents
on the child custody dispute and it's
nasty
and lori accuses joseph bryan
of raping her children and he took lie
detector text
he was interviewed by psychologists it
was determined by the courts that this
just didn't happen
so in april of 2018 joseph ryan is found
dead in his apartment and the medical
examiner determines he's been dead about
a week
and that he had a heart attack well this
recording was six months later and it
was one week before
she met chad dabal and she's talking
about how when she's going through this
battle with joseph ryan she wanted to
kill him she wanted to murder him she
just wanted the bleeding to stop
and she kept looking in the scriptures
for justification on murder
and she found it in her words that if
someone did you
did did you wrong three different times
that you could kill them which of course
is not true
and now phoenix police have agreed to
look again at joseph ryan's death
joining especially in terry austin's
absence is attorney julie rendellman so
julie at this moment neither defendants
are charged with murder in
any deaths could that shocking recording
come into the trial velo and her
current husband are scheduled to face
for hiding the bodies of the two
children
so you know look i mean this is once
again we
we know this woman um is surrounded by
death um and it starts to become a
pattern
of events where every person that she
seems to touch or know
ends up in a grave and i think what's
troubling about this
is the fact that you know you hear her
basically finding a reason
in the scriptures to kill her husband
and one wonders what she may have found
in the scriptures
to kill her beautiful children will it
come in there's going to be an issue of
whether the
probative value outweighs the prejudice
i think the prosecution
does have some arguments specifically in
other areas that she talks about how she
ended up in hawaii
but time will tell whether or not
they'll be effective in getting the
judge to do that
yeah questions of relevance and whatnot
so brian do we anticipate murder charges
ever happening here and if so
how many i think from like a legal
standpoint you can't really anticipate
you've got to wait till you get the
facts but
from a lay person's perspective there's
only so many bodies that can be buried
around you until one of them ends up
being a murder charge against you and i
think it's a matter of when rather than
if at this point
many questions surrounding this case
will continue to follow it here at the
law and crime network
yet another court hearing to discuss now
in the ongoing saga of convicted wife
killer scott peterson
a jury sent peterson to death bro for
the 2002 murder of his pregnant wife
lacey
but california appeals judges ordered
both a new penalty phase
and a re-examination of the conviction
itself the issue is that a juror may
have lied about her opinions and beliefs
to get on the case and to ensure a
conviction so
this hearing was about whether peterson
should receive
a new trial among the issues is whether
peterson can be moved
to the san mateo county jail in
california while the process plays out
peterson is at san quentin right now the
state prison
and has been unable to speak with his
attorneys in part because of the
pandemic
so julie that's what we learned from the
hearing that he just faced
this process though of deciding whether
or not the whole case needs to be done
over again is dragging on and on and on
when are we going to get a decision here
so look we have a decision regarding the
sentencing and we know that
based on the fact that the judge kept
out those jurors who
didn't believe in the death penalty but
yet were willing to apply it he
basically said you cannot be on this
case
and what the defense counsel is saying
well doesn't that kind of impact on top
of the other potential jury misconduct
doesn't that
impact the entire trial isn't that an
issue when it comes to these
jurors sitting on the guilt phase and
that's
what he's dealing with now keep in mind
the pandemic is slowing down
everything so it's not surprising that
this would still be an
issue that you know hasn't been resolved
i'm not so sure he's going to be
successful at the end
because a lot of the case law doesn't
seem to
be in his corner okay so brian does this
process make sense we we've got
a definite new penalty phase and a
possible
entire new trial absolutely i mean
wherever you
fall on the on the scale of scott
peterson as guilty should be put to
death or scott peterson
there's some sort of reasonable doubt i
think we can all share the same idea
that due process needs to be kept here
and if we're going to
kind of write that final note of putting
him to death we have to make sure that
all the boxes are checked
and we did it the right way otherwise
the system isn't working well a decision
is of course forthcoming one of these
days in whether or not the entire case
will have to be done
again and still ahead here on law and
crime daily an update
on the case against jacob blake who was
shot and paralyzed by police in kenosha
wisconsin over the summer
plus measures to reform the way police
departments operate in several major
cities
passed during the 2020 elections we
explained what charges
are in what changes rather are in store
and why they're important when long
crime daily returns in just a moment
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody voters in several
cities passed police reform measures as
part of the 2020 election
brian's here with a look at some of the
changes brian erin so
here are just some of the measures which
passed voters in san francisco voted to
abolish mandatory staffing laws which
actually required a minimum
of 1 971 officers to be on the force at
any given time
in san diego voters passed a measure to
create an independent police review
commission
in pittsburgh voters expanded a citizen
police review board
and similar oversight measures passed on
the ballots in columbus ohio
and philadelphia emily galvin almanza
ceo and founder of partners for justice
spoke with me
about many of these changes can you talk
to us a little bit more about what
exactly a civilian review board is
absolutely so a civilian review board is
an incredibly important tool for a
community to have in
controlling the way they are policed all
too often as we know police don't do a
great job of policing themselves
they don't police themselves or they let
themselves off the hook so the internal
affairs bureau
of a police department may not be
holding officers accountable for abusive
actions towards the citizenry
a civilian review board is a group that
gives the citizenry power to
investigate police to hold police
accountable now
it's a really broad range of what powers
they can have
but when a civilian review board is
given certain powers like many of the
ones you just mentioned were
the power to subpoena officers the power
to perform investigations to have legal
counsel and sometimes even the power to
hire and fire
officers in the department that can
really protect people against police
abuse
when you see numbers like this voting on
things like civilian review boards
what do you think the people are really
like pushing for and do you think this
can
expand to other cities in america people
who worry that talking about policing at
all or
you know stepping back from our current
model of policing
is a political third rail should look at
these numbers and really reflect on
the sort of astonishing majority support
that measures to reign in police have
gotten and some of these civilian review
boards
basically some people would argue are
just a rubber stamp from the internal
investigation from the police department
so if they don't have the teeth or
really the
the ability to do what you and i are
talking about here
is there really a point for those types
of civilian review boards
that's a real danger and we've seen
review boards without
power pop up across the country and
that's not to throw any shade on the
like incredible people
who have worked on those review boards
those people by and large have wanted
more authority and wanted more power to
do good in their community
but in the past we've seen a lot of
civilian review boards that for example
did not have the power to subpoena
police did not have the power to fully
investigate
the complaints that were being brought
to them by civilians in other words
you'd have a civilian saying hey
officer you know jones beat me up and
beat my brother up and i know four
different people who he beat up
and he planted drugs on my sister and
the civilian review board wouldn't be
able to
look into officer jones's other cases or
check on whether
prosecutors had been dismissing a large
number of his cases because there were
problems or
subpoena medical records that they might
need to verify those claims and without
the power to take
action this is again a body with no
teeth
you can find misconduct all you want if
you don't have the power to act on it
that increases the police feeling of
impunity
that has already done so much damage to
their behavior and the way they police
communities
many officers and sheriffs are saying we
don't have the money to prop
up this civilian review board let us do
our own internal reviews this is a
redundancy we already have these reviews
let's not spend more money so what do
you kind of say to that argument of
we could do it ourselves let's let's
save money and put it elsewhere
i would say if they've been doing it
themselves this conversation wouldn't be
happening
sorry i would also say that um i mean
it is demonstrated that the police are
not doing a good job of policing
themselves
that ship has sailed when a bad acting
police department gets sued and they do
get sued
they are paying out millions and
millions and millions of dollars a year
to settle these suits now where is that
money coming from is it coming out of
the police budget
usually not uh astonishingly very often
when police do something wrong and they
get sued and the court says yeah you
guys screwed up
and orders them to pay you know five
million dollars to an aggrieved family
that money comes out of the city's
general coffer very often so taxpayers
are paying that money for bad acting
police police don't sacrifice their
budget when they act badly
they don't lose any money so this goes
back to not having any consequences and
not having
you know being able to proceed with
impunity
a tiny fraction of the amount of money
that most of these departments pay out
in settlements is all that's required to
robustly fund the civilian review board
and what can that review board do clean
up the department ideally i mean if
they're given
real power and real investigatory
capacity and the power to hire and fire
they can actually get rid of
some of the officers who are most
responsible for costing taxpayers
millions and millions and millions of
dollars because of their abuse
brian buckmeyer there along with the ceo
of found of partners for justice and
coming up after the break a sudden end
to
a case against a man shot by police in
kenosha wisconsin
and later on in this broadcast the
second phase of the trial against a pro
baseball player accused of triple murder
with a bat
a jury must decide whether the defendant
deserves the death penalty
[Music]
the kenosha wisconsin man shot by police
last summer will not
go on trial as planned to face sexual
assault accusations
law on crime's angenette levy is live
with an update on that case angenette
well erin when kenosha police confronted
jacob blake last summer you'll recall
that he was facing a sexual assault
charge
involving the mother of his children
that charge has now been dropped along
with a criminal
trespassing charge as part of a plea
agreement
now blake has pleaded guilty to two
misdemeanor counts of disorderly conduct
and will spend two years on probation
he became known across the country after
he was shot in the back
seven times in august by officer ruston
chesky
that happened after the accuser in
blake's sexual assault case called
police
reporting he was on her property when he
shouldn't have been
that officer claimed he thought blake
was trying to kidnap one of his children
as he ducked into his car and that blake
had admitted he had a knife
which was later found in his vehicle
however blake's attorney denied he had
been carrying a knife
the shooting left blake paralyzed from
the waist down and sparked nights of
civil unrest in the city that became
violent at times
seventeen-year-old kyle rittenhouse is
accused of killing two men during those
protests
he claims he acted in self-defense now
the u.s justice department launched a
civil rights investigation
into the shooting and the wisconsin
department of justice investigation
into the shooting and the officer's
actions is ongoing at this time
aaron and jeanette thanks a lot for the
update so brian any surprises here
legally about two years of probation for
a couple of misdemeanor pleas
not really i mean this i know for our
network we typically see the big cases
the murders the rapes the
the big names but when it comes to
charges like this nine times out of ten
and i'm sure julie will agree as well we
often find ways
of taking plea deals and probation for
something along like this nature
seems correct when i only have so many
facts so julie you're a former
prosecutor do you think the shooting
influenced prosecutors in the way they
offered the deal in this case
i don't and you know i you know again we
i've read a couple things about it it
seems to me that the reason that they
lowered the offer was because the
complainant with regards to those
specific
allegations wasn't being cooperative and
so they wanted
you know to get something and so they
went for these two misdemeanors instead
of the sexual
assault cases that were originally
charged and so the fact that the
complainant didn't want to participate
goes a long way in a prosecutor making a
decision
you know to try to resolve it with some
type of resolution some type of play
julie renneman and brian buckmeyer good
insight on what happened behind the
scenes potentially in that case
a couple of quick updates now on other
cases we're following new mexico state
police announcing the arrest of 27 year
old candy joe webb
they say she loaded her grandfather up
with xanax and ambien to kill him
when he was dead she loaded his body
into a tool chest and dumped it
u.s marshals caught her on the run in
jacksonville florida and took her into
custody
the st louis couple seen pointing a
handgun and a rifle at protesters
outside their mansion this past summer
is suing a photographer mark and
patricia mccloskey say the news
photographer who captured the most
famous images of them
was trespassing on private property in
their gated community
and caused them quote humiliation mental
anguish
and severe emotional distress and when
we come back here on law and crime daily
we're back to california as prosecutors
seek the death penalty for a man whose
attorneys say
has a mental health issue and an episode
was behind a triple murder
[Music]
brandon willie martin beginning court
with his head in his hands the former
pro baseball player standing convicted
of a triple murder
the jury found martin guilty of slugging
his father his uncle
and a security system installer to death
with his own baseball bat
martin now faces a possible death
penalty in a second phase of his trial
prosecutors asked a jury to consider the
brutality of the attack and
how defenseless the victims were when
recommending
a sentence
and getting beaten time inside and sign
again
and of course if you consider michael
martin
in infinite watching
and waiting ricky anderson was still
alive
when he went through rick's pockets
as he laid there dial
and rummaged through his pockets
rummaged through
welcome barton's pockets and paris
swanson
stealing their personal belongings
that's a circumstance of a crime of a
crime that shows a characters
on the part of the defendant and then
through an insult to injury he drags his
own dad's body
into the garage
the defense said their client is
mentally ill and therefore should
not be executed
everyone in the family they don't know
what to do any folks thought he had a
drug problem
john i think he's got something more
than that
thank you misty dr
a month later in february he's diagnosed
as
schizophrenic paranoid he's given
vilified by psychotic medications
he's gonna come and tell you that look
at the date that's about
two and a half years before murders in
this case that's important
because he was suffering
so julie here's the big question should
the alleged mental illness that's
proffered by the defense
nullify the prosecution's attempt to get
the death penalty here
so again we talked about the death
penalty and here we have now
three people dead um a brutal brutal
crime but we also know that
he had been in a mental health
institution
they were supposed to keep him 72 hours
they decided not to keep him as long as
they should have even though the mother
begged them to keep him begged them
saying
something is going to happen and so i do
think a jury's going to sit there and
say
it is a brutal crime he's responsible
for it
but the mental health mistakes the
mistakes of kind of society and not
handling it will have a huge
impact on whether or not this specific
individual should be put to death
for civil liability we have a very
different argument here but for criminal
liability brian do you agree with julie
absolutely i mean call me old school i
don't like the idea of putting people
with mental health issues to death in
this country
there's i think that should be a point
here that the prosecution should not be
seeking the death penalty when
we have such clear evidence that would
suggest i know it's not proven as yet
and it may not be proven we haven't seen
that as yet but even the suggestion that
there was some serious
mental issue i think that should be
taken off the table and then you look at
this case i think this family's had
enough depth in the family
let's not add to it many opinions about
this case and certainly the jury will
get the last word remember of course
there's a moratorium on the death
penalty in california so even if the
jury hands out that punishment
the governor's order prevents it from
being carried out julie appreciate the
guest appearance here on law and crime
daily brian thanks again as always for
being here with me
we'll be back again tomorrow with terry
austin as we discuss justice in america
right here
on law and crime daily
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre
law and crime is the only network that
has it all good evening and welcome
this is a complicated case don't really
jump to conclusions
we break down the case of a serial
killer another day of drama between both
sides
from multiple live trials daily to
original and compelling programming
the law and crime network is everywhere
and we invite
you inside the jury box this
is lawn crime
[Music]
[Music]
you